[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir à la fin du cumul
des mandats c'est imminent à partir du
1er juillet prochain les députés ne
pourront plus être simultanément à la
tête d'un exécutif local
en clair fini les députés mr cette
réforme c'est un coup de pied dans la
poudrière temps le cumul de mandat était
ancré dans les moeurs de nos politiques
la france suit l'exemple de ses voisins
européens se réjouissent les partisans
de la moralisation
d'autres au contraire alerte sur les
limites de la réforme exercer un mandat
local permettait aux parlementaires de
garder contact avec le terrain avec nous
pourrons discuter pascale poirot vous
êtes entrepreneur candidat aux
prochaines élections législatives dans
la 2e circonscription des yvelines
erwan le gall vous êtes premier adjoint
au maire de maurepas et olivier plus n
vous êtes maître de conférences en droit
public à l'université versailles saint
quentin
bonsoir messieurs pascale poirot il
était urgent de faire cette réforme
oui je pense qu'elle aurait même dû être
fait il ya bien longtemps parce que
enfin pour tout un tas de raisons sur
lesquelles on va revenir mais je pense
que notamment pour les mandats nationaux
on pourra y revenir je pense que la
nation mérite que député s'en occupe à
100% et ne partage pas son temps avec un
autre mandat il ne partage pas son temps
avec un autre mandat erwan le gall vous
avez une réserve
est-ce que ce lien avec le terrain avait
des vertus
oui alors il ya des vertus en premier je
voulais comme dire que c'est toujours
extraordinaire que l'état ce sont ces
son rôle s'immisce aussi dans les
institutions c'est son devoir
mais là encore une fois il s'immisce
pour dire que faut stopper le cumul des
mandats si ça ne l quelque chose qui
était en désaccord complet avec le
système
les électeurs sur la peau en juger et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
tous les députés maires ont été réélus
ou alors non réélus
ça s'appelle la démocratie donc ça ça me
gêne aussi parce que c'est à dire que
encore une fois on s'immisce dans un
système et la deuxième chose sinon on
reviendra après so cumul des mandats là
c'est sûr composition député maire il ya
autre chose
il ya d'autres bien sûr mais il ya aussi
le cube sur la longueur et sage il va
falloir aussi en discuter après on dira
juste après ma réserve
oui évidemment je trouve que l'ancrage
local est important vraiment
c'est pas une mauvaise voie pour moi si
on est d'accord avec cette loi
alors je leur ai souhaité qu' on a
encore plus loin dans la démarche
vous me direz juste après olivier puech
justement sur cette loi
ça a été évoqué la première phase au
nicolas sarkozy puis françois hollande
du coup ça traîne dans les tuyaux depuis
assez longtemps
oui c'est à dire que deux commissions se
sont prononcés sur le sujet à la
commission dite balladur qui a conduit à
révision constitue de 2008 qui a modifié
la moitié la constitution et la
commission dit jospin sur voilà la
déontologie de la vie publique
sachant qu'en réalité c'est un sujet qui
est encore plus lointain puisque ces
commissions se sont inspirés de ce qui
se fait dans d'autres pays c'est ça
parce que la france était un peu à la
traîne il faut le dire on va dire
qu'elle n'est pas allée par an en avance
sur beaucoup de choses a été en avance
sur certaines institutions le conseil
super de la magistrature maintenant là
beaucoup de retard en la matière il en
va de même pour le cumul des mandats
pourtant en termes d' avance la france a
affirmé dès 1789 que les députés étaient
bien les représentants de la nation et
n'était pas lié par un mandat impératif
parce que ça c'est une subtilité
importante les gens l'oublient peut-être
mais les députés
être député c'est un mandat national
voilà c'est un point important parce
qu'alors ce qu'il ya dans ce débat le
non cumul des mandats est un moyen
il faut aussi donner quel sens il a ou
quel but
ils recherchent quel objectif il
recherche aujourd'hui je pense que
le sens qu'on doit donner à ça c'est
qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est que faire
la politique
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un engagement
politique et dans quelles conditions on
peut le remplir correctement et donc le
cumul le non cumul et est un moyen est
là où je rejoins monsieur le gall c'est
que c'est presque dommage d'avoir été
obligé de faire une loi pour en arriver
là
parce que un peu comme les britanniques
disent il ya la raddho et le soft law
donc c'est à dire quand est ce qu'on est
obligé de rendre quelque chose légal ou
quand les acteurs d'un marché où les
acteurs d'une organisation où les
acteurs d'une association
professionnelle se donne un code de
bonne conduite
mais on a besoin de règles en fait pour
on a décrié l'absence des députés à
l'assemblée
les parachutages etc on est quand même
dans une ambiance tout à fait défiance
forte donc on a sûrement besoin de
règles exactement mais c'est parce que
les acteurs en place n'ont pas su
adopter un dock un code de bonne
conduite ou des comportements vertueux
pour mieux remplir leur mission qu'à un
moment le législateur s'est dit bon ben
il faut en passer par la loi pour y
arriver
erwan légal c'est la faute de notre
député de nos sénateurs qui ne sont pas
de bons élèves
si vous pensez que depuis être député
maire munich temps députés ils vont
siéger pleinement à l'assemblée et il y
aura pas de parachutage
franchement non je crois que là où il ya
tout à l'heure j'ai dit qu'on n'est pas
allé assez loin dans la démarche et qu'
ils y apprennent de rémunération aussi
je pense que fin je pense pas assez pas
assez cher rémunérés mais bien sûr un
niveau de 2 meur sur des strates
d'habitants
entre 20 et 40 mille comment voulez vous
qu'ils allient ça avec une fonction le
professionnel moi je le vis sur une
strate d'en dessous de 20 mille à dix
neuf mille deux cents habitants avec le
maire qui s'est pleinement engagés sur
la ville mais pleinement engagée mais la
rémunération d'un maire surface adverse
la rémunération d'un mais ces deux mille
et quelques euros brut
il faut avoir une fonction ou alors vous
avez géré ou alors vous allez chercher
d'autres fonctions électives pour
suppléer à ça et c'est ce qui se passe
et même à tous à tous les niveaux parce
que faut pas se tromper même un hadj ou
lorsqu'il a des indemnités et c'était
pas un salaire c'est des indemnités qui
viennent se greffer par rapport à son
absentéisme
si les salariés donc en fait quand vous
mettez en cuben ça fait là pour une fois
un cube et à 0 la variable 0 c'est votre
cas vous mais moi je suis chef
d'entreprise 17 entreprises bien que
c'est l'argent à faire au moins ce que
je fais pas mon activité commerciale
mais bon ça c'est pressé une volonté
c'est un choix mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'élus en france
peut-être trop et c'est là où il fallait
il fallait aller plus loin c'est adrien
moi j'ai été chercher les ratios le taux
de représentativité d'élus par habitant
on est 1 % 4 en france en autriche en
est un pour 209 et je vais juste qu en
irlande un pur 2336 assez d'autres
systèmes
mais vous voyez bien que la variable est
quand même énorme
c'est à dire que cela de les lire par là
à se dire que ça devient un métier et ça
veut dire que c'est un métier rire
d'elle avant le signalement dit non mais
dans ce sens noble que lorsque j c on se
sacrifie pleinement un mandat ou deux et
c'est pour ça que je dis dans le temps
dacca - il faut savoir s'arrêter
ou alors passer à un stade inférieur au
bout de deux mandats c'est terrible
d'état le 2 juin aux députés en fin
ou mr mais après passer la main et je
crois que là où on n'est pas allé assez
loin c'est que dans cette no cumul des
mandats c'est qu'il ya une nouvelle
génération qui va arriver
comment va-t-elle arriver comment va
être mise en place
là il ya un problème on en parlera juste
après olivier plein sur ces questions de
rémunération de nécessité d'avoir un job
à côté en fait tout simplement pour
vivre alors juste avant je vais revenir
sur une petite chose qui m'a un peu
étonné dire que l'état est intervenu
pour finalement mettre fin au cumul des
mandats cela paraît poser problème mais
qui votent la loi
ce sont quand même les parlementaires à
qui on reproche de justement de cumuler
des mandats et finalement ce sont bien
les acteurs qui indirectement ont
conduit à ces réformes certes pas en
déposant leur bulletin dans un isoloir
fin et on s'en tient à ce besoin de la
société à cette demande un peu de
groupes de plus de morale
il ya un besoin mais ça concerne
finalement le comportement de ce qui
faisait la loi
donc c'était à eux de prévenir ce risque
en adoptant ces comportements bien avant
il ya de mauvais arguments effectivement
la question du niveau de d'indemnités
parce que ne s'agit pas de rémunération
est critiquable puisque dans ce cas il
vaut mieux effectivement réduire le nom
de collectivités le nombre de mandats je
crois qu'il existe en france 500 milles
de mandat c'est simplement colossal eux
voulaient dire 500000 mandat c'est à
dire à travers quoi les conseils
je ne manifeste au niveau local 640
milles
voilà c'est encore pire ce que je ne le
pensais donc ça veut dire que bons en
comparaison d'autres pays
il est possible de réduire cela surtout
quand on a un nom de strates en termes
de collectivités territoriales qui
devenu presque inimaginable
voilà entre les intercommunalités les
régions qui n'existaient pas voilà il ya
quelques décennies à peine la solution
effectivement voilà nos
donc réduire les collectivités
territoriales pour évidemment réduire
aussi les postes qui nécessite de les
administrer
pascale poirot est alors sur la
réduction du nombre d'élus là je partage
je partage l'avis aussi de monsieur
légales notamment des élus nationaux moi
je préférerais effectivement moins deux
députés moines sénateurs 577 députés
aujourd'hui 510 ses débuts de ski et ça
fait partie des propositions et est donc
en vaudrait mieux qu'ils en aient la
moitié ou 60% enfin peuvent en tout cas
significativement moins mais qu' il
fasse vraiment leur travail et pour moi
l'argument de l'ancrage local pour moi
c'est pas un argument parce qu'il ya de
multiples façons de s'en créer
localement par exemple il suffit de
créer une entreprise une famille je veux
dire que vous prenez le métro vous voyez
les problèmes de circulation
vos enfants à inscrire à l'école à
lierse idée
des démarches administratives de toute
nature je veux dire c'est la vie que
rencontrent les administrés si un élu et
professionnels de la politique parce
qu'il a un mandat local qu'il prend
énormément de temps un mandat de député
et qu'il fait plus rien lui même parce
qu'il a cinq ou six personnes autour de
lui qui font toutes les choses pratiques
pour lui il va être aussi déconnecté et
je pense que c'est ce que reprochent
d'ailleurs beaucoup nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui aux hommes politiques par
rapport à un chef d'entreprise ou même
un salarié d'une entreprise qui qui va
rester ancrée tout en ayant un mandat
qui est compatible avec son activité
donc vous pouvez aussi et dans des
associations enfin je veux dire ya des
millions d'association en france c'est
une des grandes caractéristiques de
notre pays dans lequel on peut
s'investir donc sous réserve
effectivement que la rémunération d'un
mandat politique est suffisante pour le
sacrifice que ça représente sur sa vie
professionnelle et sa vie associative
moi je pense effectivement il faut un
rayon nombre d'élus et d'autre part
faire en sorte que les hommes politiques
ne se spécialise pas à 100% politique
parce que c'est là qu'ils risquent de
perdre le pied avec la vie réelle
alors il ya peut-être deux poids deux
mesures c'est à dire qu'il ya des
députés qui sont maires de petites
communes
mais quand on parle de gérard collomb de
dom 2 voilà très charismatique qui ont
en plus de ça plein d'autres fonctions
dans les intercommunalités et c est ce
qu il faut pas séparer ces différents
cas est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire
une loi un peu plus
au cas par cas en considérant le nombre
d'habitants des communes parce que c'est
on parle pas de la même chose quoi
divers points par rapport à ça c'est
vrai que d'être d'être député en ayant
une activité il ya très peu de chefs
d'entreprise députés et pourtant ils ont
tout les toutes les les compétences et
les ficelles oui parce que maintenant
une collectivité ça se gère comme une
entreprise reconnue en dix ans il y as
j'ai appris ça 140 députés qu'ils ne
renouvelleront pas leur mandat parce que
ça fera leur sixième mandat d'affilée
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui vous choque c'est
le renouvellement des mandats ordinaire
donc temps vous là pour répondre à votre
question qu'est-ce qui sclérosent tout
système c'est que c'est les partis
politiques c'est à dire que il ya un
ancrage local d'une tête d'affiche bon
cette tête d'affiche donc mais a pris
tout est verrouillé dire que les jeunes
je me considère jeune en politique et
pourtant j'en fais depuis l'âge de 16
ans mais je suis je vous êtes aussi un
professionnel de la politique finalement
non non je suis chef de maintenant je
travaille non non je travaille à côté je
travaille je suis délégué 50 ans une
délégation sur saint-quentin en yvelines
ça me prend du temps mais on se doit pas
se laisser envahir non plus par alain
chabat et on doit avoir une gestion de
son propre emploi du temps
je suis professionnel dans le sens où
j'y mets beaucoup de temps d'énergie et
de conviction
lorsque je fais voilà je pense que ça
c'est aussi important
le jour où ça mènera plus j'arrêterai et
je pense que beaucoup de nos hommes
politiques devraient en faire autant
certain moment il faut que sa famille
est toujours une petite flamme
oui et l'éthique il faut arrêter quand
on quand on est plus dans l'enthousiasmé
des débuts
c'est pour ça que mon métier de faire
vous devez faire attention à ça c'est
dans le sens noble dire que de deux
cheminées réellement sa carrière
politique pour obtenir des à des fins et
on le voit bien là cette période
présidentielle
les ralliements pas revoir mais c'est
juste pour obtenir des postes et c'est
juste insupportable
c'est ça que les français ne veulent
plus olivier plein certains disent que
ça me donnerait plus de poids au
parlement de vérifier que les députés
sont bien là sont assidus parce que
cette idée vous sont correctes oui cela
peut avoir un impact 1 c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui généralement les travaux
parlementaires sont sur trois jours
mardi mercredi jeudi et les jours au
restant ils sont tancés conscription
injustement pour opérer ce lien avec la
circonscription mais à limites
que vous ayez un mandat local ou non
vous pouvez vous rendre circonscription
pendant ses jours donc ce lien sera
toujours toujours nécessaire là où il ya
une certitude c'est que avec cette
parfois une confusion entre le mandat
local et le mandat national cette image
du député-maire du sénateur maire les
gens savent à peu près ce que fait la
personne en tant que maire en tant que
président du conseil départemental du
conseil régional mais il ne voit pas
souvent ce que fait le parlementaire
oui ça reste flou et ça reste flou
pourtant les informations peuvent être
trouvées sur le site des assemblées
parlementaires mais il n'y a aucune
information
je n'ai jamais vu pour ma part deux
députés le maire sénateur maire un
maître dans c'est un tract de campagne
son bilan de parlementaires généralement
ça passe pourquoi c'est si peu visible
l'activité du député ou du sénateur
parce que beaucoup d'administrés n'ont
pas nécessairement conscience de ce que
doit faire un parlementaire il y a
quelques semaines un député est venu
faire une présentation d'amphithéâtre
auprès d'étudiants je crois de
de troisième année j'ai demandé combien
d'étudiants étaient capables de dire
quel était le nom de leur député
une seule étudiante a su répondre je
n'ai pas posé la question concernant les
sénateurs et concernant les députés
européens
c'est encore autre chose c'est encore
autre chose mais le cumul a eu comme cet
effet négatif de mettre de côté le
travail parlementaire regardez sur 6 des
assemblées parlementaires le nombre
de ceux qui font un véritable travail
législatif pour ne prendre que celui-ci
vous serez étonné des parlementaires qui
cosigne des propositions de loi à la
chaîne vous en avez beaucoup des
parlementaires qui déposent des
amendements en propre ou des
propositions de loi en propre vous en
avez peu et si vous prenez les
propositions de loi pour aller oui les
choses à proposer des lois déposé des
amendements c'est peut-être en trou qui
a trois fonctions
1 c'est effectivement voté la loi
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
évalue les politiques publiques à ce
qu'elles peuvent mais alors c'est je
rebondis sur ce que dit monsieur qu elle
on imagine le député d'abord c'est assez
nébuleux comme il le dit surtout si la
demande à celui de maire ou de président
de conseil général va écraser l'autre
dans la vision des électeurs ce qui pose
déjà un problème et le second c'est que
en france on n'en conçoit l'action du
dépité comme faire la loi ou participer
à la construction de la loi alors
comment ça c'est ça mais pas seulement
ça c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est on
à une inflation de loin et les deux
autres fonctions du parlement qui sont
le contrôle de l'exécutif et
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
qu'on a voté l'année précédente où les
années précédentes
enfin c'est mon opinion de citoyens est
complètement sous sous sous effectué et
donc on ne mesure pas l'action dans le
réel impact des lois qu'on a voté deux
ans trois ans alors c'est à dire qu'est
ce que vous nous dites qu'est ce que
font les députés
la plupart des lieux dans les députés -
le fait qu'il y en ait qui ont alors
c'est vrai que c'est choquant qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'absentéisme mais ce qui
est passé moi ce qui me choque pas c'est
pas l'absentéisme lui-même c'est la
raison de l'absentéisme
si la raison de l'absentéisme c'est
parce que nos députés sont en train de
faire leur travail ailleurs soit à
l'étranger pour trouver les meilleures
solutions qu on pourrait appliquer en
france où des sujets où une commission
une commission parle pas le
parlementaire qui leur demande de faire
tel ou tel travail ou qui sont dans leur
circonscription pour rendre compte aller
à leurs électeurs de ce qu'ils font et
essayer de percevoir les besoins locaux
les faire remonter au gouvernement ou au
parlement ça ça me choque pas le
problème c'est que l'absentéisme et et
nombreux parce que effectivement ils
font d'autres choses qui ne sont pas du
ressort de leur mandat de député
erwan la gare où ils sont absents parce
que ils sont dans les rouages depuis 25
ans et que le genre de il ya des débats
qui ne les intéressent pas ou qui
connaissent déjà la finalité
donc ils ne viennent pas il ya juste à
voir les débats qu'il ya eu pour le
mariage pour tous ce débat qui a duré
jour et nuit la nuit les gens qui sont
venus débattre et et des députés qui
défendent leur cause
et quant à 2 heures du matin avec des
gens qui portaient lors leurs
amendements devant 12 personnes parce
que je pense qu'il faut sincèrement
je ne vois pas le nom parce que vous
êtes en train de dire sur le cumul et le
non-cumul je vois pas ce que ça va
changer au niveau du parlement puisque
de toute façon ce sera quand 577 députés
absentéistes grande présence esther
cajus je pense je pensais ça manque
c'est un faux débat
enfin ça c'est vraiment vraiment vous
êtes là pour ça pour l'ex vraiment je
pense que c'est un faux débat parce qu
il y aura d'autres raisons parce que on
parle sur des mandats précis député
maire mais après ils ont aussi d'autres
fonctions qui ne rentrent pas dans le
cadre de la loi ou dans des conseils
d'administration ou ce genre de choses
voilà donc où pas bon donc de l'absent
this il y en aura quand même ce malgré
malgré cette nouvelle loi malgré cette
réforme je pense olivier plein sur les
exemples peut-être d'autres pays qui
peuvent nous dire si ça marche ou pas
oui tout à fait mais avant cela il faut
voir que
sur l'absentéisme dans un gros travail
ne fait pas dans l'hémicycle mais en
commission 1 dont beaucoup de débats
sont tranchées aurait été en amont
ensuite il faut faire les choses c'est à
dire que là c'est une avancée pour
favoriser la présence des parlementaires
et surtout favoriser le travail effectif
1 c'est bien plus cette question là que
celle du présentéisme en inde et un
parlementaire qui là pour être présent
cela n'a pas d'intérêt raconte celui qui
fait un produit un travail un
l'initiative de contrôle voilà c'est
important c'est une étape effectivement
il y en a d'autres
alors sur le droit comparé certains pays
déjà au niveau des pourcentages au
niveau 2
le sénat avait fait un rapport sur la
situation de sept pays européens
la moyenne de cumuler autour de 20% et
ça ça on est autour de 15% en allemagne
10 % en allemagne tentant de rendre
cette voie là en france on est autour de
75% à 50% moins de monde car voilà 193 1
3%
82 % pour les députés contre 77% pour
les sénateurs ce qui est complètement
paradoxale alors que les sénateurs
représentants des collectivités
territoriales
tandis que les députés représentent la
nation 3 pascal par un dernier point sur
le sur le cumul des mandats dans le sens
le nombre de mandats successifs dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises privées enfin en tout cas
dans les codes de bonne conduite c'est
pas toujours appliqué un administrateur
ne peut être considéré comme indépendant
après en général deux mandats de cinq
ans ou deux mandats de six ans c'est à
dire après 10 ou 12 ans après on
considère qu'il est vraiment trop dans
son moule pour pouvoir avoir le recul
nécessaire et la réflexion nécessaire
pour faire son travail correctement
si c'est vrai pour une entreprise privée
combien plus ça devrait être vrai pour
la france donc il faudrait prendre
modèle sur la gouvernance d'entreprise
il faudrait prendre en tout cas
certaines choses de la gouvernance
d'entreprise est en tout cas des bonnes
pratiques qui ont fait leurs preuves et
qui sont applicables dans le cadre de la
politique
erwan le gall sur les lieux du futur est
ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura plus de
de la société civile
comment comment vous l'imaginez je suis
pas anti société civile mais mais moi
comme les gens l'appellent ça oui mais
ça passe vite ses limites si on le voit
localement dire que lorsque vous devez
prendre une décision et on dit bon on
fait de la démocratie participative
on se rend bien compte que sa peau c'est
limite vraiment parce que tout le monde
veut gouverner mais une fois qu'on
confie les les commandes publiques et
plus personne
d'ailleurs pour preuve depuis 2014 il
n'y avait jamais eu autant de démissions
d'élus locaux
voilà donc ça c'est une preuve les
responsabilités sont gens pensent qu'il
faut avoir un chez main où il faut
entendre la société civile très
clairement je pense que les les tabs
entendre ce qu'ils brandissent qui
gronde à haut niveau de la france et
puis est vraiment courageux là je
reviens sur le cul et sert qu'à un
moment il va falloir peut-être supprimés
les départements parce qu'on voit que
méprendre prendre réduire réellement la
masse parce que il faut être plus
efficace efficient et eux connaissent à
un système d'entreprise bon ça me va
très bien sûr comment vous imaginer
l'avenir pour les élus j'aurais
d'équipement l'avenir c'est souvent le
pacéen sur la question du cumul des
mandats la constitution de l'an 1 celle
de l'an iii 7 248 prévoyait que des
députés n'est pas le représentant de la
circonscription mais de la nation
il ya beaucoup de regrets qui existait
déjà par le passé on a oublié
d'appliquer puis cette complexification
du fait un après la première république
du passage avait abusivement la
monarchie et on a on a complexifié
l'ailé les choses on va on peut revenir
à plus de sociétés civiles sans
nécessairement complexifier les les
choses par exemple sur cette idée sur
laquelle la société s'il peut conduire à
faire évoluer la loi en matière de cumul
des mandats c'est revenir à des bons
comportements
c'est c'est comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est aussi aux parlementaires
de s'interroger ce sont les mêmes
dirigeants politiques de se poser des
questions il est quand même étrange que
en 2017 on soit encore dans cette idée
donc sion n'ont pas donc si on dit vie
mais donc si on du suffrage aurait le
dernier mot plusieurs choses d'abord un
parlementaire enfin c'est marqué dans
l'article 27 de la constitution le droit
de vote des membres du parlement et
personnel donc moi l'élu du futur je
voudrais que ce soit quelqu'un qui soit
indépendant et même si à un moment il a
été obligé de prendre une étiquette d'un
parti pour être élu il faut qu'ils
répliquent qu'ils votent en son nom
propre et non pas sur ordre de son parti
ce qui se fait actuellement est
quasiment anticonstitutionnelles dans
bien des cas ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose sur votre question sur
les strates et civils sur la société
civile moi je pense qu'effectivement il
refonde il faut problème en plus de 109
mais attention
les collectivités locales ça se manie
pas quand même comme une entreprise et
il faut donc alors moi je suis
évidemment je suis connaisseur des deux
parce que j'ai conseil des collectivités
locales pendant 30 ans mais j'ai vu des
chefs d'entreprises qui n'ont pas trop
bien réussi dans leur métier de
politique parce qu'ils ont ils ont
sous-estimé la façon de s'adapter au
management d'un acteur public donc votre
solution en deux mots et bien statut de
l'élu formation il faut probablement
qu'il y ait plus de gens comme qui est
plus de gens du privé qui viennent mais
à ce moment là il faudra prévoir un
retour dans la série dans la sphère
privée alors qu'aujourd'hui les
fonctionnaires ont un avantage pour se
lancer puisqu'ils ont un parachute que
d'autres métiers n'ont pas et ça il
faudra vraiment aller plus loin que le
non cumul des mandats en ayant un vrai
statut de l'élu à mon avis pour qu'ils
puissent faire leur métier dans de
bonnes conditions
d'accord des allers retours entre la
sphère publique la sphère privée merci
messieurs d'avoir participé à ce débat
on se retrouve quant à nous la semaine
prochaine merci très bonne soirée
[Musique]